did you really move to new york city
with sixty dollars in your pocket
i did i go to new york
i moved to new york with 60 bucks and
two bags
and i just knew that i wanted to become
a better writer
and i was totally disappointed and
disenfranchised by
my future film and how that went so i
was like i'm just gonna go there and i'm
gonna just be a great writer and a
friend of mine had an extra room
in his house and so i stayed in this
extra room and not to
maybe like a year later i had enough
money to get my own place
what were in the two bags just closed
okay all right you want to make sure you
look good though
that's good these pumas i had these that
i needed to throw away they had holes in
the side of them
the tread was worn down on them but
because
those are the shoes that i had carry
through my journey i just
never wanted to get rid of them so it
took me forever to get rid of those
pumas but
yeah they were they were in one of those
two bags
i have something like that too and it is
it's a reminder
it is that there's a history behind it
yeah yeah where you've been
you don't want to forget you don't want
to forget where you've been
and how did you travel did you travel by
plane or you drove
but i didn't i didn't pay for the flight
one of my really good friends like it
was
my time it kind of wound down in atlanta
would have where i produced my project
and i needed to get i needed a place to
stay
essentially i mean you hate to say you
were homeless
but essentially it's true i mean i
didn't have the lease or money to get
anything
and a friend of mine he um got a ticket
for me he said i actually have an extra
bedroom
out here in new york you're welcome to
stay and i went up there and
i stayed in this place and quickly found
a job and just tried to do what i needed
to do to get my life back on track
what was that time like in the airport
while you were waiting for the flight
and checking
in i knew it was the right move
when i was in the airport headed to new
york i knew it was the right move
but i didn't know why i was had always
thought
i would one day live in new york but i
had not made a single plan
in my life to move to new york and i
just remember getting to laguardia
and literally stepping off the plane and
i knew
that's where i was supposed to be
nothing nothing in me said otherwise
i knew that's where i was supposed to be
there was a film festival
and a film was that any part of the
motivation uh moving to new york
yes the i had done a feature film called
lesson before love
and i have put so much work time and
effort into this feature and this was
kind of in the beginning when ava do
renee had done
middle of nowhere and she had done um i
will follow
so you started seeing like d reads doing
these movies there were all these micro
budget black films that were like
getting attention
barry jenkins had just done medicine for
melancholy so i'm thinking like
all i have to do like all i have to do
is
make a film and if i make a film it'll
be significant enough for hollywood to
come calling
but i made this film i got into this
incredible film festival out in
hollywood and i just knew
something would manifest i just knew it
and nothing happened
nothing happened and i just had my film
and all these dreams and they were just
sitting there
and i was like nothing's happening for
me in atlanta my money's drying up
i need to just be better for myself and
i thought what was wrong was i wasn't as
strong of a writer that's what i needed
to be
and so that's why i decided to go to new
york because i'm like the best writers
are writing theater
right there in new york so i went there
to just absorb and learn and grow
and how long had it been since you had
finished that film
um it was the same year it was the same
year so i did the film in 2000 at the
very beginning of 2011. and then
um went on a film festival circuit i
only got into like four festivals
only had enough money to submit for
those four so hey
but um yeah got into those festivals and
just thought like
everything would change and nothing
nothing changed
nothing at all changed and it went from
being
what i thought was going to be my
calling card to like just another
project
and i didn't know that you just have to
keep doing your next project and not
necessarily worry
about the end game and i was so focused
on the end game that first time which i
think is really what set up all that
anxiety and depression that i went
through for a few years
before you moved to new york you had a
job
in was it organ donation yeah
and this was like a dream job and you
were rising in the company
and you had plans i don't know if you
were saving up for a house or you were
doing some things
yes so i got in this job this was right
after
hurricane katrina and i got a job like
right
during that time and so i never thought
that
organ donation would become a passion
point for me and it did
and so i worked the job and i was doing
extremely well within the company and
then all of a sudden
they gave me a new position moved me to
new orleans in 21 days they let me go
like literally walk me out of the front
door
with security and change the code as
soon as i get outside
and i never felt like that ever in my
life and i thought this was going to be
my career job that i did in tandem with
making films
but that's not what the design was was
about did you tell them that you were a
filmmaker
they knew so
i know employers get nervous at that
time i always get nervous and i don't
know i don't know why necessarily either
because i think people having an outside
passion actually makes them
better at their job because it gives you
something to look forward to
as opposed to just coming back home or
going back to work on monday
and so they knew and they knew that i
had done some plays
they knew that i had some things going
on but
i just i don't know if it was jealousy
or interview or if i just didn't
meet the corporate culture that caused
me to get fired but
i got fired and it took me a long time
to recover from that
and so do you look back on it now that
it was almost a blessing in some sense
because your life has taken many turns
you went to new york now you're here in
l.a
yes i think losing that job really was
the the impetus that was needed for me
to kind of really start my career
because beforehand i mean when you have
the cushy job when you have the money
your passions almost just inevitably
take a back seat
and so when i lost that job i had saved
up this money
to buy a home but now of course you
can't buy a home
no job and so i made my first feature
film
in the way that i felt on that set the
moment that i said action
i knew that's what i was supposed to do
and that feeling
is the feeling that has guided me
throughout my entire career
like when i have that feeling i know
that it's right and i know that's what
i'm supposed to be doing
so i look at it as an ultimate blessing
at the time
but it did take me through a lot of
emotional turmoil losing something that
i felt like i was supposed to have
also too i'm sure like losing trust in
people having been in a similar
situation i know
you do you lose faith in like
a lot of different things it's easy to
get jaded and so
did did there were there things that
helped you out of that
um i think it really just took time to
be honest with you for me to get from
that place of depression and i didn't
even
know that i was like even like depressed
from having lost that job i really
honestly didn't know that
and i never really had a clinical
diagnosis but now that i'm looking at it
i saw the state of depression means that
you can't move
either way and so knowing that i was
there for so long
i think it was really time and my
filmmaking passion that really helped me
kind of get out of that that place but i
did lose faith in people
i did lose trust in people i kind of
still operate just like that
i'm having something taken away so
violently i knew the potential for that
to happen again is always possible so
there is a part of me that is still
extremely guarded but i also know that
um you know
things are aligned in order the way that
they're supposed to happen
yeah what advice would you give to
another filmmaker on
having um a plan b or c or d
whatever because i think you know you
had this plan for this movie
and then it happens to a lot of
filmmakers where they think that's going
to be the one
to just quote put them on the map and it
takes several other
projects yeah i think one of the most
difficult things that happens
to a filmmaker is for them to have a
plan for their project
and did not meet because then the mark
of success becomes something that you
can't control
well our job is simply now i realize
it's just to create
that's what our job is and the universe
will do
what the universe is supposed to do so
now when i make projects or when i'm
talking to people
or giving any type of advice i always
say just
focus on creating and everything that
follows
is what is supposed to happen period
point blank
but if you say oh i'm going to do this
project so that i can get into sundance
and you made a project which is the gift
that's the hard part and you don't get
in the sundance
then you feel like you weren't
successful and that's not the case the
success
of your creativity was in making the
project
everything after that has nothing to do
necessarily with you or the project
it's just how that is supposed to move
throughout the world and you really
can't control that
so when you had this job you were
planning on doing these projects
maybe on the weekends or you know
balancing it around the nine to five
world
decided well when i was um working at
job i thought
that i was going to write this script
and then spike lee was going to call
i literally thought one day he would
just hit me on the phone like dude you
still having to have a script and i'm
like
yes i do spike lee but uh that's just
not
that's just not how it went in order for
me to have gotten to the place
to start creating i had to be in a space
that identified this is the only
opportunity that you have
so it had to happen that way in order
for me to have created that project
and if it hadn't i would have never
found my purpose because i had not made
a film before then i had just been
writing
i didn't even know that a short film
existed
i went to a film festival in new orleans
and
i thought it was for like feature films
and i'm like of course i love movies
and then i'm like wait did that just end
in nine minutes
i'm like wait i didn't know it was a
short
film and so that's how i got the thought
to oh
wait i could take a little bit of money
and i can do that
and so that's where it kind of came from
where was this voice coming from telling
you to make a short film
wow the voice where was it coming from
yeah i think the universe speaks to us
in so many different ways
and um i didn't know i
always wanted to participate in the film
industry but i never knew
how i could participate i literally
thought all i was gonna do
was write films and so when his voice
came to me and said
you can make this i think it came from
universal alignment
and it was like the only thing that was
facing me that i could do
at the time and um i did it
i made the film and i remember seeing
action
that's what it was i said action on the
film set i didn't even know i was a
director
i literally thought i was just putting
the project together so that the person
who was filming it could do all that
he was like oh no no you're the director
and i was like director i am
i was like what do you do he said you
say action and cut and so when i first
the first moment that i said
action i knew it was the same voice that
said
make this film he came back and said
this is what you're supposed to be doing
do you think you take more chances now
because of this
situation that happened to you that this
really life-changing
you think you take more risks now i'm
not afraid of anything
because of losing everything because
once you lose everything and you have
nothing
but your creativity but yourself you
started to
you start to redirect what's important
to you and before i thought it was
having a home i thought it was having a
car
i didn't know that the greatest value
that i held on to was my creative
abilities
and so now when i had nothing that's
where
really what gave me the the
fearlessness not to not to lose anything
so now
i can take those risks i could go do
point rp i can make this decision and
make that decision because it's not
bound by things
it's just bound by my internal purpose
and what i'm trying to make happen
what was the first time you wrote a
screenplay what was that like
the first time i wrote a screenplay it
was in
sheer anger i was in new orleans and i
was trying to
act and so i would go on auditions
all the time and i would always read for
the same parts
and so i remember this one time going
into this audition
and i read this part and the casting
director she's like oh that was really
good she's like that was really good
i just need you to make it a little more
um
black and i'm like
okay okay so i actually read it the same
way i did it the first time
just to let her know like i did read it
black
so i did it again and she was like oh no
good good good good but
one more time do it again i need to just
be more
just like black and i'm like okay and i
read it the same way
again and she said i don't think you're
getting it i said well can you
demonstrate it
can you show me like with this black and
of course she does this stereotypical
you know homeboy i guess black thing
that
no black people really actually do and
so
i remember leaving out of that audition
and i said i can write
something much more authentic than these
roles that i'm getting
and so i went and i sat down and i wrote
this screenplay about
three actor friends who wanted to come
to hollywood
and the challenges of them making their
career happen as actors
and within it i gave all the actors so
many different roles to play
to show that you can write an array of
different things and nothing is
necessarily defined by your race
so that was the first screenplay was
called in between dreams that i ever
wrote
and what what was the role that you were
always going out for like
was it i mean it was always thug number
three i always read for thug number
three number four somebody named mumbles
it was always that type of like
stereotypical role
and this was in the like the 2000s
you know so it's not like it was you
know back in the 80s and it was a lot of
those stereotypical roles because a lot
of those
doing that error that was coming out of
like the love jones era the love in
basketball where it was like a lot of
black romantic comedies
but now they were heading into the
direction of doing more hard edge
films so there were a lot of thug type
of roles that they wanted me to audition
for and i did
and i never got any of them because i
don't i don't make a good thug
and these were all in louisiana or
georgia okay and then there's a lot of
auditions there
there's a lot of auditions so part of
the tax um credit that they give
to the productions is you have to have
so many speaking parts for local
talent and so those were the roles and
that's why they were written so thinly
is because it really wasn't part of the
production
it was just what they had to write in
order to get those tax credits
if you had five minutes to teach someone
how to write a screenplay
what would you tell them start with
character start with characters i think
the most important thing that you can
write a screen a screenplay is about
just an amazing
amazing amazing character i know when i
construct or engineer
a character i always start with some of
the flaws that kind of exist within
myself
that i know need to be healed or need
some type of attention
and so i use screenplays really as a way
to like kind of heal
some of those wounds that i have which
gives most of my work very dramatic feel
but i would definitely say start with an
incredibly rich character
and then with those characters you can
build in really really incredible
storylines because sometimes one
character may not go in this movie that
you want
they may really belong in like another
production but i always say start with
characters because
that's what movies are all about really
really great characters
and you wrote a lot of plays as well
right yes so plays have been something
that i've been writing since i was a kid
i never even thought that it was
possible to stage
i just i grew up in a very small town in
arkansas that didn't have any type of
theater or anything so
i used to just write them just to write
them but professionally i didn't really
start to really engage until i moved to
new york and i just started
writing as many different plays short
plays long form plays one hacks
just as much as possible to really train
my um
my skills in that arena so
what's the difference for me forgive me
i don't know too much about
stage plays and writing them what what's
the difference in terms of
when you start writing a stage play
versus a film
so the primary difference is um between
writing a stage play and writing a film
is with a stage play you're really
trying to
really work towards telling your thesis
and your stage place is going to be a
lot more narrative driven
as opposed to a film which is more
picture driven
so when i sit down and write a play i'm
thinking about what i want to say
when i sit down and write a movie i'm
thinking about what do i want to
show and you can have an entire scene
play out on film with no dialogue but
you can't have an entire scene play out
on the stage with no dialogue
dialogue is much more of the driving
force but both come with a lot of the
same elements
of strong characters strong pot um
as little exposition as possible a lot
of the techniques are the same but the
applications among the two are different
do you have a favorite play that you've
written like a character that you really
love
yeah i have several characters probably
my most dramatic
and god-wrenching character that i've
wrote and his name is eve
and so i wrote this play based on the
story of adam and eve
in the garden but i switched to genders
so eve is a guy
and his girlfriend's name is amy which
is a play on the word adam
and the piece is called unholy war so
he's probably my
my favorite character that i've ever
written because he's so fragile and i
think in a lot of ways
i have some of the fragility that he has
but i don't
i'm not allowed to express that
fragility and he
is in the chorus of the play and some of
the doubts and the fears and
things that he goes through are some of
the same experiences that i'm continuing
to kind of work through myself so
he's by far my favorite character that
i've ever written on a play
interesting and especially too you're so
strong looking and
you know i wouldn't see you as being
afraid of anything sure and to allow
that because
i know for so many men it's not okay to
express that right
i mean even black men we're just not
allowed to show
any type of weaknesses or softness
because our culture over time has
calcified us inside of this manhood that
we're supposed to
to represent and that is emblematic for
us so even for me
as my own type of creator i have a much
more delicate edge to the way that i
write
dialogue it's you know a little bit more
poetic it's not as
hard-edged i know as a lot of people
wouldn't necessarily expect
and so that's what i really love about
that piece and i think others like about
it is this like they get to see a black
man
in a way that they've not really seen
him before where he presents strength
but he's really
fragile and afraid and going back to
that audition
yeah they didn't want you to show that
fear no no
not at all they want when she said when
the in the audition the woman kept
saying make it more black she was saying
be stronger
that's what she was really asking me she
was like have more rhythm
to the way that you speak be more
forceful
in the presence that you have which does
which
is representative and indicative of
black men but at the same time
you can also take those same lines that
you were given
and do them in another way that is more
colorful than the experience that
she necessarily was trying to give me
and that's what i was trying to do
present a more colorful way of
viewing that character
what makes a great story i think what
makes a
really really great story is
deep down finding the humanity in
the character i really do any
mad max fury to the color purple some of
the best movies that have ever been
created the one thing that
anybody connects with them is their
humanity you take this really big idea
but you make it really really human e.t
very very human um anybody could see
what luke skywalker was going through
you know it is to find the humanity
inside of a character i think that's the
greatest stories that are told
so you grew up in a small town yes in
arkansas
did you go to a movie theater because i
know certain small towns they they have
one but it's like miles away
yeah so i very seldom went to movies
growing up we didn't we didn't have a
movie theater in our local
city but we did have a blockbuster that
was across town
and so we grew up every friday or
saturday going to the blockbuster
getting three or four
tapes vhs tapes and and popping them in
and watching those movies so
while i didn't have a big screen i did
have a screen
and that's how i was able to really um
admire
the film industry would you get excited
going there because i would like
trying to choose something that wasn't
on the wall that had 50.
uh it was the first best experience
blockbuster was the best experience
because remember it was a smell of
popcorn right when you walked through
the front door
and they had on these blue button downs
and i wanted to work there so bad so i
could get movies for free
and i must have applied like four times
i never got
here i never got hired at the local
blockbuster but it was
like our favorite it was our favorite
thing to do on like fridays and
saturdays was to go
get a movie from blockbuster i used to
have a crush on the guy that worked
there so i would go in there a lot yeah
did you ever speak to him
uh no but he took his um the roller
thing you know they had the little like
and he did it by my feet and i was like
that's a sign
he likes me
and then he left to go to college and i
was like um yeah you know the guy that
used to work here and they're like oh
yeah he doesn't work here anymore that
was just
but anyway that's all right but you have
blockbuster great
great memories yeah how do you get to a
character's emotional truth
as a writer i used to really struggle
with finding characters
emotional truths and the reason why that
was is because i had not found my
emotional truth when you're in the
hamster wheel of trying to make content
and all you're doing is creating and
you're not
living it's hard for you to really
connect to yourself
and so after i got to new york and i
really kind of started to settle my life
i started to travel a lot more and make
sure that i started to have experiences
and i started to engage in my own
personal growth
and so then when i found my own personal
growth and who i was
i was able to in an interesting way tap
into
that emotional truth for a character and
that emotional truth for me is defined
as
what the character wants to truly
believe about himself
but nothing in the world is saying this
is such so for instance a young
filmmaker
who really wants to be a filmmaker but
their universe is telling them that
you're not a filmmaker
that is their emotional truth that they
want to be a filmmaker
and i think the journey of of a story
whether it's a short story or
a film or a play is how to get that
character
to believe in the truth that's already
beating in their heart
so that's how i think that you get to a
character's emotional truth is to find
out what it is
inside of them that really gets their
blood moving that gets their heart
rate up that gets them gives them
purpose
to get out of the bed that is what their
emotional truth is
so the world is telling them they're one
thing but that's not what they feel
inside that's not what they feel inside
and for many of us that's that's the
reality you know we're like
wanting to build this business but the
world is saying you don't have the
credit score
or you're in the wrong city to do that
or you're not capable of doing it and
then
you to be able to overcome all of those
eyes to get what you feel
that you're supposed to have is where i
think the story really is
are there certain films that really hit
home for you that do that
one of them one of the stories i think
is moonlight that does that
beautifully because his ultimate
emotional truth is he deserved to be
loved
that he was worthy of love and belonging
and where he was going to get that black
didn't know
you know he just didn't know where he
was going to get that from and then you
see especially when he gets to the third
act he's so
calcified from the world that he has
quarantined himself off
all he does is work out and he does all
these drug deals in order to make money
again a very dangerous way to exist
because he had come through the prison
system but then when he meets up with
the guy at the very
end and he starts to break down that you
are worthy of love because he saw
somebody cook for him
in a very loving way he saw somebody
have a conversation with him
so i love moonlight as one of the
greatest examples of a character finding
their emotional truth even if it was
just suddenly
at the very end what about a play
yeah so my favorite play that
illustrates emotional truths would
probably be the mountain top by katori
hall
she did a play that's about martin
luther king
and kame which is a woman
who was working in the hotel that he was
standing and this is the night before
his murder
and so the emotional truth that
martin luther king was trying to come to
end that piece is i'm prepared to die
like i'm ready for this death but again
when he shows up into this hotel room
this woman is talking
how much he's needed how much he's
leading these organizations and how much
how important he is to the movement
which tells him that he's not
necessarily done here
so to see that exploration in the course
of that which was
a two-hour two-person play which was
phenomenal
again was another way of me being able
to see
how someone gets to their emotional
truth that was totally different from
the way
that it was done in like moonlight and
sorry it is based on a real-life
character
martin luther king yeah but at the the
uh the
hotel yeah no so she's totally
fictionalized it's a fictionalized
example of
what he experienced the night before and
it is a stellar piece of theater
interesting it is stellar yep wow
so he knew he knew it was coming because
the co-intel pro and all the different
things
i think you always know i think you
always know
i think you know when it's time to move
on i think you know
when it is time to stay i think you know
when it's time
to deal with something that you don't
need to really want to deal with i think
the universe always tells you
those messages and no signs or in uh
martin luther king's case when it was
time for him to die
i think he knew i think we always know
what ruins a story for you
inauthenticity
is that how you say that yeah
when when you know that it's not
authentic
that is what really just ruins uh
a film or a story for me when you know
this is not the exact
example of what this person would have
done felt or
truly believed i think it just takes it
always just seems to take me out of the
piece that's when i
when i when i see it's not authentic is
it the acting or is it the writing how
the character is portrayed i think it's
a little bit of both
at times i recently saw a play on
broadway
where a woman was dealing with a very
hard situation as far as
her son and trying to figure out where
he was and how he was
but i could also tell that the story
wasn't
authentically written it didn't come
from an authentic place
i think the actors did a phenomenal job
with the material that she was given but
i feel like they were trying to tell a
story
as opposed to letting the story come
from within
i think all of us get stories all the
time and we want to go out and just tell
those different stories but i think the
ones
that resonate the most they come from a
place
of authenticity not saying it
necessarily has to be your story
but it has to just be authentic and if
it's authentic people will connect with
that
right there's always i mean especially
now there's a debate on
can someone really tell a story about
struggle or whatever
if they haven't really lived it yeah you
know especially if they've lived a total
opposite
right right but the reality because i
kind of faced that with a recent project
that i had done where i didn't i wasn't
i didn't have the same experience as the
protagonist of the series so i was kind
of challenged on it in some ways
but there is a such thing as a human
experience
right and once you're able to find that
human experience
um everybody's dealing with the same
things we're all dealing with loss we're
all dealing with grief we're all dealing
with joy we're all dealing with love
and we're all dealing with it in varying
ways and so
the difference between something being
inauthentic
and um
not well purposed which that happens
where people try to
tell a story that they're not doing it
is it didn't come from a very human
place
but if you come from a human place
people will always be able to
see the authenticity waves is a great
example of that the filmmaker
is white but the story is black but it
resonates
the last black man in san francisco the
filmmaker is white the protagonist is
black
but it relates because it's an authentic
human story that anybody can buy into
and believe in
yeah i really love that movie i hope it
gets nominated
yeah i hope it does too i really i think
it was a special
piece of theater i hadn't cried in the
theater in such a long time
but just to know because i've had that
experience of like a friendship that
jess has run its course and to see their
friendship fall the way that
it was just beautifully executed the
cinematographer was amazing
right and they both um you know the one
character
had more of a stable home life and they
you know they tried to kind of take him
in
but i think he knew like i don't really
belong here
yeah and i know you're trying to make it
feel like i belong here but i don't i
don't belong here
and so it was about place it was about
belonging
and um i don't want to give it away for
anybody who hasn't seen it but um
yeah it's just really beautiful film it
was an exciting piece of work yeah
it really was i hope it i hope it gets
some kind of
recognition yeah something me too you
know it's hard when a lot of stories
like that just kind of just
get shelved and
yeah that's why we need independent
cinema you know it's
when i go to do you go to a lot of
independent theaters oh i still do all
the time
still do it's gender i'm still committed
to that process because that's where i
am i'm an independent i'm an indie
filmmaker i'm not in the studio system
and in a lot of ways
while i regard it greatly i'm not sure
that that's where i'm supposed to be
just yet i'm supposed to be in the
studio system because the independent
system makes the most sense to me
i love having control over my stories
and my ideas
and to be able to accomplish those ideas
in the most authentic way possible
right and i think for i for me i don't
know maybe for you too but those are the
stories that resonate with me the most
yeah
are those indie stories not the studio
ones where
no one claps when they get up and they
and okay
you know time to go to grandma's house
now or where yeah i mean you know i'm
just saying like it's it's just a pit
stop in between where i think people
that go to independent cinema
it's to really feel something just
experience it be affected by it
absolutely and to have a conversation
with a total stranger afterwards
absolutely that you wouldn't normally
talk to absolutely
that's absolutely the case absolutely
right i hope
i hope that doesn't go away because i
know those theaters are in danger
sometimes because there's not enough
money behind them yeah
we understand you watch a lot of razzie
nominated
films what's the reason behind that
well so years ago i was
writing and writing and writing and
writing and writing
and one of my really good friends she's
a playwright also in new york she says
do i see you writing all the time she's
like what have you read and i was like
i don't read plays and she was like
you're not gonna be
great until you watch read the good
stuff
and the bad stuff you have to watch it
all and so
that didn't even make sense at the time
until i just decided to go
into the um the
playwriting bookstore in new york and i
just would pick up plays and it wouldn't
matter if i knew the playwright or not
and then you would start to see
the difference between a really well
constructed play and one that is not as
well constructed
and so the razzies i like to make fun of
films who aren't the best
that's out there and so i watch the good
stuff and i also make sure that i watch
the bad stuff to make sure that i'm
constructing narratives
in a more progressive and nuanced way do
you ever watch the bad stuff and say
this isn't actually bad and sometimes
the good stuff this isn't i'm just like
not impressed with the story
not really actually most of the time if
it's
widely kind of seen as bad i kind of
found it to be bad
you see why all right and um what i've
recently started to do was because
the the reality is even to make a bad
film takes an incredible amount of work
it really does and so i don't
necessarily go in
now to judge work but to rather glean
whatever
the artist is trying to to get me to see
from what they're trying to say whether
they're successful at it or not
that's not really for me to judge like i
used to judge in the past
but rather to just enjoy the experience
for what it is
um but i do find like as you say
sometimes the movies that everybody just
said just so phenomenal and so good
it just doesn't resonate with me as much
because i think that
in the approach to try to appeal to
everyone
you appeal to no one
as opposed to trying to appeal to
someone
and allowing others to participate in
that as well
so i think that's what kind of the
difference probably is
and for your your first film you cast
actors that you knew
is that right yes so i knew um kim brown
he was somebody that i knew i didn't
know the ladies and i didn't know the
other guy that was peyton houston
i didn't know them at the time but i
knew them they were kind of swirling
around from other people
that i knew and i knew okay i can only
have four characters i can only afford a
couple people
a couple dollars a day and that's that's
what we did
so we did a very small four-person cast
and they were pretty much in every scene
of the entire movie
what locations did you get like i got
the locations that i could get
[Music]
[Laughter]
i don't know i know it's not funny but
it is funny because
when you don't have any money you can go
right high-end
you know high-end bar with full with
patrons and a waitress walks up and does
this
but then when you're the reality of it
you can't afford
that location so i think what i would
have done differently
than what i did now is i would allow
each scene to kind of take place
anywhere
and being whatever locations you find
that made
sense in those regards would make sense
in those regards
and you do it like that so then you're
just going and looking for whatever
locations allow you in
as opposed to trying to be so specific
and not being able to accomplish it
because i think even in my first film
like every restaurant that we were in
nobody was there because we couldn't
afford
background we just couldn't afford it so
nobody was there
and we tried to make it like oh nobody's
there because
they're not supposed to be
yeah but i would i would definitely
adjust how i would do it especially if
you don't have money
you don't have money you just provide
the framework and then you go
that the universe kind of tells you this
is where you can film this is where you
can film and then put it in those
locations or a location that you already
know that you can get
forgive me how much did you spend on
your first family my first film i did it
for
45 thousand dollars yup we did it on
forty five thousand which made sense
because average renee had just done a
film
i think it was uh i will follow she did
it for fifty thousand
and so i'm thinking like oh we're right
in line with what they're doing at this
time and again it was a very
insulated isolated film that she was
pretty much at her
aunt's house the entire film had shelly
richardson whitefield in it
but ava is like a master at being able
to market and get her voice
out there you know we didn't have those
same resources and we were from atlanta
so nobody
nobody really cared about our project
it's okay
and it was a feature right it was a
feature a little bit too long
and i remember also when we went into
the first cut
i was bored out of my mind for the first
26 minutes of the film
so the first 26 minutes of the film i
totally cut out
of the project uh because again i didn't
know how to necessarily get into
story in that way and i didn't have a
mentor to kind of like guide me
and so i think that's another thing
people cannot be afraid to lose things
in the process because in losing those
26 minutes
i think i really gained a solid one hour
and 30 minute film
but if i was trying to get to this
two-hour time frame that i was initially
trying to do
we would have lost a lot of audience
from the very beginning and you cut that
in when you started editing it
yes i remember my first time watching it
and i was just like
this is not interesting and
even now when i go back and i read that
screenplay i realized what i was doing
on those first 26 minutes and why it
wasn't interesting
and so now i approach stories with a
little bit more vigor and heart from the
very beginning
and i don't try to meander as much as i
had initially done
were you warming up in that 26 what do
you think it was
i was still trying to learn the craft of
screenwriting so
at that time i was just writing from a
place of this is what everybody wants to
say
this is how they want to say it and this
is a cute way in order for them to be
able to say it but i didn't understand
the craft and the technique
towards opening the film and that your
first opening image
has to be a story itself that's why my
first film was so good with dialogue and
not real
emotion and images because i was all
about what i had to say
as opposed to what i had to show where
fast forward now
like i'm working on another feature film
which i cannot believe i'm doing
but 10 years later i'm doing another
feature film
and everything is image based so my
first scene
i'm drawing what the image is and then
i'm deriving what has to be said within
that for the story to truly live like
what information
does the character does the audience
have to have
in this moment that's a complete
different approach from what i did in
the very beginning i was very much
writing plays
on film and trying to film a play as
opposed to
making a movie that 45 000
forgive me if this is too personal but
that was meant for you to put a down
payment on a house right
sorry i wish okay
no that actually 45 was for me to make a
feature film
so we got a couple of investors to give
one gave 25 another gave 10 and another
gave
and then the last 10 was kind of like
piecemeal together
but that money was literally sitting
there for us to actually make a film
we had initially budgeted 150 000 but we
never got there
and i just decided to go ahead and make
the film which you shouldn't do
you should only make a project when you
have the financial resources to truly
support it
other than that you'll just be
frustrated as i was for that entire year
so if you could have changed things you
would have waited
i would have waited i would have waited
i would have gotten
more perspective on the screenplay i
would have sent it off to get coverage
for people to tell me what was wrong
with what was right i didn't know that
was a thing you could do at the time
i made a lot of mistakes i kind of felt
like i didn't cast the right people that
i wanted to necessarily cast
even though i cast where i was supposed
to cast so i would have made
a lot of decisions differently but i'm
glad that i had that experience
because had i not i wouldn't know how to
be as savvy as i am with the budgets
that i do have now
do you think it was because you just
wanted to make a movie so badly
yeah i wanted to transform my career i
was in a place where
i hadn't really had i hadn't had a place
to stay i hadn't had a consistent income
for quite a
quite a long time and i knew that if i
was able to make a piece that really
connected that
somehow hollywood would come calling and
it just didn't
it didn't happen like that and so i
really decided i would never make
another feature film
ever again after that experience and
even the experience of going through
what i went through as far as
distribution was concerned
and you know getting picked up in red
box nationwide
and getting a couple of dollars for it
even though
the product the district distributor
made thousands
you know so to have those experiences to
go to all those things really put me in
a place where i'm like
i want to make films but i don't want to
be a part of this business
right this juggernaut that is hollywood
but
here i am still participating
knowing that you may be rushed into
making your first feature film
and you have a lot of things that you
would have done differently do you think
it's better that you did that
rather than still be talking about
making that feature film
10 years out you know what i'm saying no
i
it was the right decision to make like i
don't
i don't fault you know i don't regret
having done the film i it was really
exciting i still watch it every now and
then i'm like oh my goodness this is
actually like a good little field
i'm still excited about it but what i
think that
the realization that i have come to is
in order to cook the meal that you need
to cook
you need to have all the ingredients on
the table and so
now i'm taking a much more realistic
approach for but with budget
i'm taking a more realistic i'm still
not in the million dollar
you know range but i am at the place
where i know there's a certain level of
professionalism that i need
a certain level of talent that i need
and so
to approach work now with a little bit
more savvy
and making sure i have those ingredients
is a little bit more important
but i'm glad that i cooked the film that
i cooked the first time
i am i'm very glad that i did that
because i wouldn't be here had i not
gone through that process
so the the the film wasn't burnt but it
it could have used maybe more
it didn't rise spice it was a cake that
didn't rise but that was still edible
okay okay yeah that's so good you can
still eat it out of the pan
but you can't serve it to the masses
okay right you know
i mean as metaphorical as we could be
you know it just didn't rise to the
level that i felt like it could have
risen
to with a little bit better ingredients
that i needed to have along the way
but it was great i think it still i
still think it was a great project
what prompts you to watch it over and
over again sometimes you just need to be
reminded
i think a lot of times with creators
because we're always focused on what's
next we forget what we've done
and i think when you forget what you've
done you lose sight
of where how much you've grown so like i
can watch my films and i see elements in
my first film that are going to be in my
new film
that i'm going to be doing like i still
do the color coding like i still
approach um scenes kind of in a similar
way but a more progressive way than i
used to in the past
i still want to throw these little
nuggets of life inside the dialogue
i still do some of the same elements so
it's nice to see
that what i made was a true depiction of
who i
am as a creator and as a person and
but it also lets me know the resources
and the skill set that i was at that
time
so sometimes you have to be reminded
that you have made progress you have to
see where you've been
to be able to recognize where you're
going i heard you say in a talk that you
gave somewhere in new york
there's a great talk and you said you
have to know that you want to be part of
this industry
do you think people really have to know
or can they just kind of like
you know try it out and see where it
takes you is it okay to be on the fence
about it or do you really have to know
that you want to be in this industry
well i liken it to um
climbing mount kilimanjaro either you're
going to climb mount kilimanjaro
or you're not you can't decide the day
before
climbing the mountain that you're going
to climb the mountain
that's how people die on the mountain
but if you
know this is what your actual goal is
then you have to put the work in to
prepare yourself for it
and a lot of that is nothing that can be
taught in a film school
nothing that could even really be
learned on film courage it is an
actual experience that you have to have
to understand
who you are how you are because the hows
really matter in this approach of making
films and being part of this industry so
i think people
have to know is 100 what they want to do
but there's also
a little bit of beauty in the the bliss
of ignorance
because had i known all of what i would
have had to suffer to get to this very
moment that i am now
i would not have done this i would no i
wouldn't have done it i didn't know
that there was so much suffering um as
that's part of a creative journey in the
industry that i find to be so beautiful
because it's that hard it's literally
climbing mount kilimanjaro
but i know how to scale mount
kilimanjaro now
because i've had so many experiences and
i've been training for so long
so i feel like now i'm in la i'm ready
to be a part of this industry i know who
i
am as a creator i know how to work with
other creatives i know how to take
studio notes now
like i know the difference between a
television director and film directing
like i understand these things now
and i needed all those small experiences
to get exactly where i
am right now but if i had the foresight
i wouldn't have done it because it's
been that difficult
what do you think you would have done
i'm not sure i think i would have been a
teacher
i love to like teach and like share
knowledge and information and i think
that's what my films are
they're just really beautiful lessons
you know that people get to see and
participate in so i probably would have
been a teacher
and i think i pretty much i put up an
okay teacher yeah i think you would have
been because that
we saw you um giving like a lecture to a
group of
filmmakers yes and you know you had high
energy and just
you know we're willing to admit where
you went wrong and different things and
and um but i just wondered if you'd ever
envisioned
what would have happened if you knew how
hard it would have been
i don't know i think it a again i just
use the my kilimanjaro thing i don't i
think even people who have successfully
scaled the mountain still didn't realize
it would be as difficult as what it was
and i think to still get to the top and
not recognizing how difficult
what it was is where the joy comes in
right that's what makes the hero's
journey
because i'm on my own hero's journey
trying to come from nothing to make
myself
relevant in an industry that i am
extremely passionate about and that i
love
so yeah but i wouldn't i wouldn't
i wouldn't do it if i could see it if i
could see it i wouldn't have done it
does your family ever call you to come
home no
they don't they knew calling me to try
to come back to arkansas would be
totally a few times
it would be a futile call they would
never make that call
and there was a lot of trepidation for
them i mean
to live in arkansas is to live in such a
safe space
you know it doesn't take much to own a
home there's a community of people that
already support that already love but
the reality is the industry
i want to be a part of exists in new
york and it exists in la
so i had to make the decisions to come
to come out here and i'm glad that i did
have you ever been tempted to compromise
your values
i have not been tempted to
compromise my values because for me i've
been leading the effort of my
productions
they've been my productions and so i
haven't had to run against any type of
executives or executive producers that
have asked me to compromise any of my
values
and to be honest and i'm really kind of
thankful that you asked that question
because it makes me reflect on why i got
into this industry and to begin with
and what i didn't think was possible i
didn't think it was possible to get to
where i am
without compromising my values and i
remember when i was like 20
22 years old i came to la with the
script that script that i had made
between you and me that i thought spike
lee was gonna pick up
i came to la and i was here for six
weeks
and i recognized in order for me to be
successful i'm have to compromise my
values so i
immediately went right back home because
i was like this is not
for me which fast forward these few
years later
i'm here and i haven't had to do any of
that
so i'm really grateful without naming
any names or
exact situations what did you feel
you would have to do and what how would
that be compromising
well the thing that i learned about la
when i first got
here is the is how the community kind of
works here
um i'm a very like
spiritual person i'm not really
religious i'm not i'm
i'm very much an empath and in order to
not be affected by those energies i
can't be around
a lot of people and i saw that when i
first got to la you have to find a crew
of people
to kind of run and to kind of hang out
with and so i could see myself
being in circles where people were
talking negative about other people
in order to make themselves feel better
and that's not
me you know um the you know kind of
drugs things that kind of was going on
and i'm like that's not
that's not me either like i don't judge
anybody for what they do
but it's not necessarily who i am but
i'm also not like a religious zelo
you know i'm like a little bit in
between there's a guy that wants to eat
good food and go to the movies
that's all i want to do and so i just
kind of could see
a lot of those influences happening and
a lot of those fluent influences taking
root
and i was like okay i'm not ready for la
but now that i'm back
while i still see some of those same
things again i'm able to address it a
little bit different than what i was in
the past
i have the strength now to say no and
plus you have a body of work
yeah so at that time when you came you
had just a few scripts
just a few scripts just a few scripts
and a whole lot of
um um naivete
[Music]
i really didn't i really did i had no
idea how the film industry in la works
and
in this past year that i've been here
while i don't i can't say
i'm like an expert i've really been able
to see and witness how the industry
works
and it makes a lot more sense now and i
see how i can navigate through it
and plus you know you can put a
production together you did it
yeah so whether you were totally happy
with the project the outcome
is one thing but you know you can get
people together you can get resources
so i'm sure that exudes a different
energy
so maybe then they know okay well this
guy i can't totally
i can't pull the wool over his eyes when
i got here
so one of the first things that happened
when i got here
was people different production
companies would hit me up for different
meetings
i remember having this one meeting and
this guy he was talking really quick
really really quick very good areas
had a very attractive personality very
attractive personality
and he was talking about like i love
send me your script i will
want to look at your project i sent him
over just like a deck of what i wanted
to he was like this is the perfect
project
and then he starts talking about that he
can do these certain
sales on the film prior to
just to get started all he needed was
like fifteen thousand dollars
and i i know when i was younger not that
i had fifteen thousand but if i would
have had it i knew i would have given it
to him
but now i'm able to note the business
and i know that i don't have to give you
fifteen thousand dollars
for me to go get money for my future
film but again you start to see these
characters and you start to see
how people conduct themselves and know
like oh
that's not what i want to be associated
with
and so i was even i was easily able to
say no this time where when i was
younger i wouldn't have been able to do
that
so he wanted that upfront money to take
on your film
to take on my film project and then
to get funding for it but i just never
heard of that structure
that finance structure that he was
saying so it made sense that this was
more of a scam
than it was an honest reality of someone
who just wanted to work with me
almost like um modeling agencies that'll
take you on
yeah if you use their photographer and
these different things and you pay this
upfront so it was almost like that like
the project hadn't finished or wasn't
even made
no project wasn't made it was just a
screenplay at the time
i still have that screenplay but he read
the screenplay said it was
incredible which of course was part of
the
the manipulation and wanted money wanted
about fifteen thousand dollars to get
just to get started and then he said you
know he's he's able to work a deal
within like
six to eight weeks and i'm like none of
what you're saying
makes any sense and so you were 21 and
you
went back home yeah with that knowledge
did he try to call
no this happened this year oh that got
happened this year
wow if that had happened to me when i
was 21 oh i would have given them
whatever i had
because i would have thought this is
this is how you this is how you make a
film this is the business
and it's not the business and i know the
business because i've studied the
business
act you know more appropriately so yeah
this just happened like maybe like six
months ago
oh okay sorry my bad i thought okay
and so how did that make you feel
knowing like
you you could have been taken advantage
of but you knew better like how does
that
it made me feel so accomplished it
really did
the one thing that i have learned how to
do is say no
and that's sometimes i have to say no to
myself like hey i want to write this
certain project
no that project isn't for you it's not
authentic oh great
and so now i'm able to flex that muscle
so it was nice for me to look him
in his eye and tell him no thank you it
was it was empowering and again
i wouldn't have gotten there had i not
done my feature had not done my digital
content had i not
gone through these scrapes and these
bruises to know
what feels right and what feels wrong
and have the power to be able to say no
after you made your first feature film
you stopped making movies yes i did
i said i would never make another
feature film again
i just was done i couldn't do it because
i didn't know
what why this one filmmaker could make a
film
that wasn't the best film ever made and
continue to make progress
and then i could make a film and nobody
care
i didn't understand that but i also at
the time didn't understand
the business you know in the business of
visibility
the business of associations of knowing
people you know
i didn't have any of that i was just
just one this young man
creating these films in my own lab and
not that many resources to get about
into the world so i had a very small
[Music]
approach and i just knew i was like this
is too hard and i'm not going to do it
so i just decided to just
become a playwright in new york as
opposed to keep making a film
so you still wanted to be creative i
wanted to create but i wanted to do it
in a place that was a little more safe
a place where i could like have regular
things like
um afford a cup of coffee i wanted to be
able to
have my own apartment and you know
be happy and have clothes and shoes that
didn't have holes in them so
i was like it's not gonna happen if i'm
in the feature film world
how long did you need away from all that
before you said okay i'm ready to kind
of like dip my toe back in
it was about six years it was about six
years um
i started to see a lot of people making
short form digital content online
that was really really good and i caught
up with
a friend and also a writer
director named raven drummer out of
atlanta and i said hey
like i have this really good idea for
this series about these two writers who
come together
to make a project there's really
something else below the surface
would you be interested and she said
sure so
she put up 2 500 i put up 25 and another
friend put up 25
and we made eight episode web series on
seven thousand five hundred dollars what
was the web series about
uh it was uh brooklyn blue sky and it
was about blue and skyler's um
journey towards creating a pilot for a
netflix and chill competition nice
yes so art imitating life inside our
imitated life and it made sense because
she was a woman and
you know i'm a man and we were trying to
make this um project but we had
something underneath it
um i don't want to tell the story okay
that's all about but we had something
underneath it that needed to be
further explored and so we were able to
put it in
in that landscape and you know
thankfully everything went really really
good better than we ever expected with
that
so you almost didn't come to la you
would have still been
in new york doing plays which doesn't
sound like a bad life
yeah i had no plans to move to la
at all um i was like no not for me i'm
gonna make it in new york and i'll never
have to move to la
but about a year ago a little over a
year ago
something something in me just started
beating this is in order for your career
to get to the next level you
have to go to la and i had a lot of fear
because i already have a beautiful life
set up for me in brooklyn
and i just i bought a one-way ticket
for january 15th of 2019 and i came here
and i've
been here ever since and creating
content and and things have been
happening
you go by your intuition sounds like yes
that's what i'm letting god by
to say yes and to say no it's by that
internal it's a muscle that you use and
the more that you engage and use that
muscle of listening to that internal
dialogue the easier it gets
right so now even with hiring like a
sound person like i know
like this is person i should hire not
that person it's just something
internal and i'm still make some bad
decisions i'm not saying now
everything i do is great and every
decision i make is the bomb
but i'm a lot more aware of why i'm
making decisions
i know what i'm connecting to in a
person whether it's generosity
or creative creative curiosity
i know what it is that i'm connecting
with someone on so it's making me a lot
more purposeful
and it's making my work a lot better
which do you have a harder time with
saying yes or no
nowadays it's harder i have a much
harder time saying yes
because now i'm being presented with
options where before everything that i
was doing was just me internally doing
it
but now you have oh you have a feature
film opportunity here you have this
opportunity to direct television here
you have this opportunity here so now i
have three different
things to look at in order to make that
decision and
all things within context make sense
but now i'm going what is what am i
truly aligned
to doing and it's hard to look at a
network and say
no thank you i don't want to direct your
television show not that i don't want to
direct your television show but i'm more
in line right now to do a feature film
so it's harder to make those decisions
and you know what you're leaving on the
table
because i could make money doing that
but i'm so but i'm guided so fiercely by
my purpose
that's the thing that i move and i only
work with people i
only work with companies that i know are
directly aligned with my purpose and
where i'm headed
do you have um someone from your past a
family member
a mentor or somebody that you really um
trust guide you do i do
um probably the closest person to me is
my sister she's been really a part of my
journey from the very beginning she's
read everything that i've done
she's seen everything she's been in all
of my readings she's been everywhere
and she knows who i am today as opposed
to who i was yesterday
and so she makes sure that i continue to
make decisions that i don't fall into a
lot of those old pitfalls
of not being able to say no or moving
faster than what i need to for the sake
of getting it done
as opposed to getting it done correctly
and so she's able to advise me in a way
that is
that makes a lot of sense and we laugh
and we enjoy the process when we do it
and she's back home yeah she's in
arkansas yeah so a lot of phone calls
yeah a lot of fun every day oh wow every
day
every day and then you had to reevaluate
why you wanted to be in this industry
and you saw that
it wasn't for the reasons you thought or
sorry i don't mean to yeah
no that's 100 correct i initially wanted
to get into the industry because i
wanted to tell
stories about myself to be quite honest
with you
and so if you look at a lot of my
earlier work it always is like a
direct reflection of me but as i've
continued to like grow
as an artist i realized the greatest
power that i had was still in my
power and agencies telling other
marginalized stories
and so i've been a person that's been
fighting a good fight
when i was a kid when i was in college
and now i'm actively doing that as a
storyteller
so i'm putting my lenses on stories that
don't necessarily reflect me
although the journeys of these
characters do reflect me right so like
for instance king esther
is about a trans woman in new orleans
but i'm not a trans woman
i'm not from new orleans but the the
human
connection of needing to be seen against
all odds
that's where we connect and so now i'm
seeing everything doesn't have to be a
reflection of myself
and so now i'm making better stories i'm
telling
more rich characters more flawed
characters because it's not
um any reflections of myself and it
sounds like too that what we talked
about earlier
that character wanting to sort of
validate within themselves and not have
it what the world's telling them that
they are
absolutely it's it's to get to that
emotional
to get to that emotional truth and
that's what i'm able to tell now
now that i know what my emotional truth
is and that is i am a storyteller
and i am worthy of telling stories that
i don't necessarily own
and now i'm actively doing that and i
love it do you feel these stories come
from some other place
yes they all come from me like i don't
think there's a character that i've
written
that didn't reflect me in some way shape
form or
fashion even the ones that i really
don't like i mean i have to admit there
are parts of myself
that i just don't celebrate you know i
don't like i know how they need to
change
whether that is again my ability
to people please i used to be a people
pleaser
and to my own detriment i'm still
actively working on that
that belief in self that i'm capable of
doing things that
necessarily haven't been designed for me
i'm having to work on that
i'm working on my graciousness being
more gracious more grateful
more humble each and every day for what
i've been given
and those people that i'm surrounded by
so as i get better and as i continue to
get to my emotional truth
and explore it i'm doing that better
with characters
and now i'm telling better stories and i
think
going back to that talk that you did in
brooklyn you had said
that you're you had to reevaluate why
you want to be in this industry
and maybe before it was being famous and
i think that's a very common thing for a
lot of people why they get started
especially when they're younger and then
it came down to just telling stories
yeah what what happened there how did
you how did you because
i think it's some people i know somebody
came at me once and they said how dare
you say that but
that's a common thing for a lot of
people they want to be famous especially
in this
this social media age absolutely because
even when i was growing up
fame afforded you a certain level of
privilege that i wanted to have i wanted
to be able to travel i wanted to have
money i wanted to be able to buy things
and so i knew being a young black poor
boy from arkansas the only way i was
going to get there
you got to become famous people all have
to know who you are
and i think there are a number of things
that really like
defined and refined what that experience
was because it's still very much a
possibility that i could become a
household name and a star
but that it's not how i identify myself
you have to get away from that id
and an ego and get to the intrinsic
nature of who you are
and i realized that i was just brought
here
to create and tell stories right
and the manner in which i do that and
how i do that
is the definition of who i am and so
when i started to see that and not have
a connection to
physical tangible things like a city or
a house or an apartment or a couch or
old pumas that needed to be thrown out i
can then
approach my work so differently there's
a freedom that i have now
there's a there's an approach that i
have now where i'm not pressed
i'm not pressed to make this decision or
that decision because i know what's for
me
is truly is for me so that was really
the difference and now that i've really
been able to evaluate that
i continue to evaluate that right and
make sure that
everything that i'm doing is just
aligned with the purity of telling
stories
and making sure that i'm doing them in
the most authentic way possible
did you used to have someone tell you
stories when you were a kid no i just
tell the stories
okay you were the one who would call
them lies
i always say stories and i just love to
entertain people through
stories even when like i'm at dinners
with friends and i'm telling the story
it's
always this this bigness to the way that
i
do it but growing up no my mom and my um
my stepfather were very very very
religious very religious
people so we were at bible class all the
time
pretty much like six days a week um we
were there doing that so
i didn't really have time to they didn't
have time to tell
a whole lot of stories so i mostly told
stories to others
well there's a lot of with parables and
i mean there's a lot of storytelling
within the bible there is a lot of
storytelling within the bible and some
of the greatest stories i mean a lot of
my work is derived still
from this story of adam and eve it's an
allegory that continues to come up
almost in all of my work
we talked earlier about there was a time
when you just got kind of stuck in this
place where
you couldn't really move you didn't want
to do this or you didn't want to do that
and you didn't know it was depression
yep you talk about what happened
yeah so when i started to understand
what a depression
was um there's the clinical definition
when you really get down to it is you're
unable to make a decision to move
either forward or backwards where you're
really stuck in this very specific place
and so when i first moved to new york i
didn't realize that i had been going
through
such a depression because i wasn't able
to write i wasn't able to i mean
a play a essay anything i wasn't able to
do anything
and i also wasn't able to make a
decision about what my life was about to
look like
and so when i started to deal with that
i definitely
decided to get with a therapist and to
start really working through the process
about where i was and where i was
eventually trying to go
and after being able to identify a lot
of like the decisions
that i was making in the present were
rooted in a lot of stuff that i had done
and dealt with in the past
like losing my job and trying to prove
to people that i had worthiness
even though something very valuable to
me was actually taken away
and so one of the things that the
therapist said that really began to
transform me was one he said nobody is
responsible for your life but you
and how you engage and give back to you
is you do the things that you
want to do the things that you enjoy the
things that make
you happy and through that you will be
able to kind of start seeing the light
at the end of the tunnel
and so that's when i started to go to as
much theater as i could in new york
and it was just like a seed that had
been watered
you know where it was like i was dead in
my creative ability
i started to really flourish and start
coming up with the ideas
and started to see the definition of who
i was and there was just one specific
play called sunset baby
written it by dominique morrison that i
think really was just
it really defined me and my personal
journey because she was trying to just
go get on the flight and get away
and that's all i was ever trying to do
was kind of get away
and escape the past instead of embracing
the past and using it as the fuel
to create everything in the present just
kind of what i went through
and i was able to get back on the other
side and fortunately i haven't
experienced that in a long time
sunset baby sunset baby and you saw that
in new york i saw that in new york at
the
labyrinth theater it was unexpected but
it was such a great
piece of poetic work it was just
tremendous
did you reach out to the playwright no i
never did i've never reached out and
it's
interesting enough because i've met
other writers who know exactly who she
is
and so maybe you know maybe the universe
with the line and i'll be able to one
day see her look in her face and tell
her hey this play really helped heal the
journey that i had internally
so did it also heal but then you also
wanted to write
plays like that where that were
affecting and i understood
that the what made it so effective is
that it came from a very real place
inside of her
and again i wasn't writing plays because
i was trying to hide so much of who i
was from the rest of the world
i wasn't able to authentically tell
these really deep and rich stories
so once i started to be okay with me and
who i was i was able to go out
and start really telling stories in a
very authentic
and rich way and while it not has not
necessarily caught on to the popular
culture people that have been able to
witness my work have been affected by it
and that's what i'm grateful for do you
remember what it was like to leave the
theater
after you saw that like were you in one
of these dazes i was
it was hard to get to that theater too
because that theater is like not by the
train
and i remember not one not wanting to
leave the theater i didn't really want
to be defeated so i just kind of
remember
sitting there for just like a half
second longer than what i should have
and then immediately we went across the
street and i just wanted to just like
regurgitate and just talk about
the peace and talk about the journey and
and it's been so many amazing plays that
i've seen
in new york so many incredible plays and
playwrights that people probably would
never see that workstage but
it's an incredible group of writers and
talent to pull from in new york
we often hear from people that you can't
make money
making films short films feature films
is there a way to make money from it or
is that not
that shouldn't be your goal starting out
well so
i do think that you can make money from
the film industry i mean clearly people
make
millions of dollars these there are some
beautiful houses
in la that was built on film money
i do think you think you can make money
from a film i think what a lot of times
filmmakers initially do even with the
short films they forget to pay
themselves
and so what i've started to do even in a
line item of a film that i've invested
my own money in i still will put one
dollar for myself
and it's to continue to train myself to
realize that i do have a monetary value
that is attached to who i am and what i
do but what i think
also oftentimes that filmmakers do
is and this is what they should do
whenever you're putting a budget
together for a feature film you have to
also think about the life of what that
film
is going to be right so if you're going
to live with that film for six months
you also need to make sure that your
expenses are covered for six
months so part of your budget when
you're establishing your budget should
be to have money to pay you as a
director to live for those six months
that's one of the things that techniques
that i didn't do very early on but now
i actually look absolutely i'm like was
this a two-month process
i need two months of this kind of money
from the budget and so i state that up
front
and also one thing that i would also say
that i think filmmakers should
absolutely do
is say what you need as well right
because we always speak from a place of
just talking about the project
making sure the project we want to make
sure the project has
the right camera we want to make sure it
has the right light in the right
location the right actors
but the project comes from a person so
you also have to make sure
you as a person has what you need
to be okay as well and so whenever i
talk to filmmakers i preach that from
the very beginning make sure that you
pay yourself
as a part of the process but as far as
the
film's um ability to be monetized and to
make money
there are people whose job is to do that
and you should go find those people and
make sure that you get in contact with
those people
to make that happen because it's not our
job
to make the money it's our job to create
the product
and make the money after it's out or get
paid
up front well i think a filmmaker should
definitely get paid up front
for their fees i think they should also
negotiate
some type of ownership in the project as
well
however whatever you get initially
whatever that initial sale is on your
film is all the money that you will get
like period point blank i have not heard
of a film doing amazing at the box
office and then a filmmaker making
millions
with certain level of ownership so you
also have to come in from a very
realistic place
as well so that's what i would advise
somebody to do get
you should be a line item in the budget
you should own some of your product
but that initial sale you should benefit
from that as well
that initial distribution sale that's
where you're going to get your money
you're not going to get no more money
after that
can you give us some examples of ways
you've been able to make money
with films or stage plays sure so
primarily how i've been able to make my
money over the past three years have
been in short form digital content
and so one of the ways that you can do
it is
you figure out what networks are
actually looking for
from time frame to um
what specifically has to be inside the
frame and so i end up making brooklyn
blue sky for about
seven thousand five hundred dollars i
got another small investment on the back
end to do some editing
and then i was able to send those
projects over to bet
as i knew bet was starting to look for
digital content because we were
initially going to just put it on the
internet
but we started working with this
producer named chris hicks and he was
like no
like bets actively looking for content
so we were able to license the content
at a pretty nice rate per
episode and so that was able to pay the
budget back
but then because i had ownership in the
series i was able to use that money
to live off of for an entire year
i also was able to do that with sars
the project with that as well except
they gave us a big budget from the very
beginning and we negotiated a larger
budget and then we just held some of
that money back for me to actually get
paid in order to do
what i needed to do later on down the
line
so if you make a project for a little
bit amount of money but you're able to
get a larger licensing fee
that'll be able to give you some actual
revenue
that you're able to create along the way
so mostly it's been short form content
it's been short for content because
people are looking to fill up those
content
avenues in the content arenas also i've
been able to
work and recently start working with
different brands who are looking to
create content as well
short form digital content because
that's of course my specialty
and from that you can also make money as
well because a lot of brands are looking
for their stories to be told
in a very linear digital way and so
you're able to utilize that as well
different brands work with them in order
to create stories
and you can make money off that as well
and did those brands approach you or
you were already working with someone
who was working with those brands so i
actually approached the brand
believe it or not sometimes the empty
mouth just doesn't get fed
so i would put together a small package
i did it for a wine company i did it for
another
um liquor company i said hey
i make short form content this is what
my views have been
combined with your talent and your
resources
it could be much more and this is a
story idea that i have for you
and here's how we would do it and this
is what it would look like and two of
those brands
picked up on it and that's another way
that i'm able to use my storytelling
abilities
in order to to make money and did you
research which brands you should go
after did you say i think
i would be right for this one or so with
uh
one liquor brand i had a friend that
worked in that field so i already had a
direct connect
and then the other one was a connect
through a
manager that i had and she was able to
connect me over to them and i was able
to pitch it
but i know in the next year or so that's
what i'll be working on a little bit
more
that'll be a separate side of my
production company where we actually
really start to turn those different
types of projects out
and um how do you contact those people
do you send an email like oh just a
quick pitch
you can do a quick pitch a lot of times
a deck
some type of visual deck for them to be
able to see really works
a lot of times people don't know what
they want until they actually you show
them
what they want and then it makes sense
and also you're able to create something
at a much lower price point than they
would they're able to make commercials
at
so they look at you and they're like oh
this only costs 250 000 we get
eight episodes at 10 minutes apiece as
opposed to them putting 1.2 million
dollars into a commercial that's 30
seconds long
and so it is an attractive bid for a
brand to be able to create content
because they have the budgets
to be able to put more content and
everybody's into storytelling right now
so they have the money to be able to put
those things out there
and so are you once you have the budget
then you're finding the talent or they
already have people in mind
so i manage the projects as as they're
my own projects with taking advisement
from them
a lot of times brand don't necessarily
have talent because it's a very new
thing
to use brands in order to tell stories
so it could be a story about a guy who
needs to find his dog
and the brand could be about dog food so
yeah they may have like an idea or two
but most of the time for me what i've
seen is they just allow
me to go out there and to procure the
talent to create
and to make the production when you
return to filmmaking what changed for
you
my perspective changed my perspective on
what i wanted and how i wanted to get
there
it really really really changed i didn't
now look at it as an opportunity for me
to become
famous or a star but rather for me to
intrinsically tell
really really great stories and because
my approach changed so did my attitude
so then i could just enjoy it for what
it was and i could send it to sundance
on the sunday and says no i'm like
it's no problem i still made a great
project you know where is it supposed to
go
and then it gets into this film vessel
i'm like that's where it was supposed to
be
so my perspective really changed because
it was it
no longer became about the money or the
fame or any of that it came
purely about my connection with the
audience and if they're
if i'm able to successfully get them to
see the story that i need
them to see then i was a success and
that's where i see success now
i think i heard you say something and i
love this you said
the way i wrote this down you said you
just do it straight dewy
and and what is that that's great i just
do it my way
i do it my way on set i make sure every
i know everybody's name
um when i'm out at film festival
i wait to shake the very last hand like
i'm doing
everything the way that dewey does it
and i'm only working with people who are
kind of just giving me the space to just
do my dewy thing
you know which i'm jovial um
i'm i'm open i'm very
focused on what i'm doing yet i have a
very nuanced perspective
on this industry and on you know my
creative approach
so i'm just doing it the way that i do
it and i don't worry about any other
creators or how they do their thing
or what they have or what they don't
have so just
do the dewy i just do the doing i like
it yeah
did you did you feel that growing up it
was okay to be you no
not at all i grew up in a town where i
really
felt i felt so small i felt so different
it was a town of people who didn't
reflect any of the experience that i'd
had or had known and i always felt like
i was fighting
to be seen and i was always
out the way that i saw the world wasn't
reflective
on the environment that i was seeing so
i didn't feel that it was okay for me to
be who my most authentic self was
and i think after my first feature film
and me moving to new york and just being
in this environment of creative people
who are just being authentic
and like me seeing like it is okay to be
myself it is okay for me to
to to love everybody it's okay for me to
look at the world
from an international place as opposed
to just being a domestic place it's okay
so when i started to give myself the
permission to experience myself in the
fullness of who i was
that's when everything would really
start to change and i'm like you know
what
this is who i am this is how i am this
is the kindness that i have to give
i'm going to give it i'm going to keep
creating to keep keep it moving and
that's how i work
and how did life change for you
everything has magnified
so i remember when i moved to new york i
had 60 bucks i had
two bags that's all i had i had lost my
furniture i had lost my cars
i had lost all of the things that i
thought defined who i was
and then i remember just using my
universal intuition to be able to see
how i was going to move forward certain
things
whether i should do this play whether i
should do this short film whether i
should work on this music video
and then slowly i started to see all the
things that i had lost came right back
i got a bed and i got a car and i got a
couch and i had this and my appreciation
for it
was so different while still not being
attached to any of it at all
right i could lose everything tomorrow
and i'll still be doing dried
right i'm still going to be kind and i'm
still going to create and i'm still
going to have purpose
because it's not defined by what i have
it's defined by who i am
and that's how i kind of have lived my
life since then
did you approach issa rae about king
esther or did she approach you
uh the producer caroline robinson she
had approached denise davis over there
who was kind of
um
issa's right hand and so we they were
the first people that we had connected
with
about king esther but at the time it
just they were trying to do some new
things digitally
we hadn't really gotten out on the film
festival circuit and so
we just kind of had a meeting of the
minds and so it was nice that when it
came back around
and we had looked at all the options on
the table we chose the option that we
had kind of all
found from the very beginning which was
issa rae's production company
and sorry it was already finished it was
already finished yeah so it was finished
we
even when we initially caught up with
them we had sent them the version of
king esther
and they really really loved it and saw
the value of it that they weren't ready
to like release on their network or
anything like that at that time
and then when we came back later
everything was just beautifully aligned
for
the for the both of us to work together
on it and king esther is about what
so king gaster is a short form digital
con series about a transgender woman in
new orleans seven days before hurricane
katrina
and her decision to either stay or leave
as the
as the hurricane comes to town yeah so
each episode is for one day
in her life uh leading up to
august 28 2005. and do people know that
she's trans
or yes so she is notice a little bit
she's noticeably trans in this series
and
as it's a part of the series it doesn't
encapsulate what this series is all
about
it could have been about any character
but it's just about esther who just so
happens to be trans
but it's nice for us to be able to kind
of also have explored her and her
journey
a little bit as um as well and how she
was going to get there but it has all
the elements of
family discomfort love belonging
singing dreams it's all it's all
woven in there inside the story and you
wrote it
yeah i wrote it i wrote it directed it
produced it
so what made you want to write it um i
had written a play
called the inevitable sadness of all
things good which was actually about her
brother and so
um there came this this time where i
would do different readings for it in
brooklyn
and people always loved the piece but
they really liked esther but they knew
that authentically she wasn't where she
needed to be
and so to really to really exercise
myself
and telling stories of people who don't
belong you know necessarily to the same
experience that i've had
i started to just etch out her story and
i started to write it and i started to
do an incredible amount of research
about the trans community
their stories their journeys their
authenticity the way that they live and
the fullness of themselves
and then i just encapsulated all that
into this story where the common
denominator
across all was the humanity and empathy
and that's how i made the story
has anyone reached out to you about it
yes so
we've had people from sundance to reach
out we've had networks reach out
we've had a lot of peop there's been a
lot of movement on this series which is
really really exciting because it is a
series that people
and it tells a story that's something
that people really haven't seen so it's
nice to see people
you know so active about that and it was
nice to have
options on the table before we just us
decided to go
with uh easter egg color creative
presents do you think if you had written
it
15 years earlier it would have the same
you know because
now there it feels like there's way more
acceptance
whereas people have been trans for years
you know growing up in the bay area i
would see people all the time
but it was definitely not accepted
except within small circles but do you
think now it has
way more of a life to it yes i think the
normalization
of us recognizing that gender is not
monolithic
that there's different ways that people
are being able to approach
gender and the openness today is what
has given way to her success
but i don't think that had i done this
back in you know
2000 and um
that it would five or anything like that
it would have had the same
gravitas that it had now i think it
would be probably would have had a
little bit of more of a cult following
so people would have
watched it you know in the cover of
darkness but it wouldn't have been able
to be what it is now
i think now was the perfect time
especially on the
of her story of pose
and other things that continue to
introduce new and different
stories to the fold where does the money
come from
for a web series like with king esther
so
money can come from a couple different
places as far as
like a short form digital content series
a lot of brands are beginning to engage
and do their own short form content
cuibi has that every major network has a
short form digital content arm
new form specializes in short form
digital content essex
essence magazine just started a essence
digital studio so
they're there and they're funding
content in order
for stores to have a life online
but also so that's one way you can get
funding but also we went through way up
we went we went private equity
so i invested money into king esther
caroline robinson invested money
ryan robertson he invested money so we
had people john mallow
that came together and we funded it
together also another incredible tool is
crowdfunding a lot of people are
beginning to utilize that as well
in order to get in the short form
digital content space and the only
advantage that i really see of short
form digital content is that it can be
licensed
so you can make content if you make it
for an inexpensive cost
it can be licensed for someone else to
be able to pick up and to utilize so you
can monetize those
efforts so when you approach these
different people
to be investors had you already written
the script or you told them that you
would do this what spoken word or this
play
and people really liked this one
character right so
um one thing i know about raising money
that you in order to really raise money
in an appropriate way if you don't have
a household name is you already have to
have the product ready to go
and you have to have some type of
creative um
proven track record to go along with
that so people saw the success that i
had with bet
and brooklyn through sky so then it was
a much easier introduction to say
hey here is my other piece of content
that i would like to do next
and again when after i did that i was
able to walk
into brick and say this is what i would
like to do and it was a fully funded
effort from a production company
so as you have to make these different
investments and hopefully the next time
i do it
i have even more money to really create
the resources and things that i need to
do to film the way that i need to film
so you just have to kind of create this
little bit of a track record but the
script
was the one thing that people needed to
see in order for them to make that
investment um
tangible and you said so it was already
how many episodes was it seven
seven episodes they were already written
when i um
sent it out to for people to make an
investment inside of it
did anybody try to say can we just tweak
this one part can we make this not too
noticeable
can we not touch on this topic too much
or did they say the opposite
it needs to be more in your face they
were so open to the way i wanted to
create
and that is the beauty of people
trusting in your vision
and if you don't prove that from the
beginning and people don't trust you
then they do hit you with notes they do
say hey this is how i would like to see
this
because they've never seen you execute
but because i had executed
a a really well done well crafted
product
and people read the script and saw the
the dearth of what i had kind of put
together
they had all the trust in the world like
this is exactly what it was supposed to
be
it was also really nice for us to send
it out to a lot of trans organizations
to make sure that they could
put their eyes on it and make sure that
the experience that
esther was having was absolutely
authentic
and and they agreed they agreed
everybody loved esther
everybody loves them some esther so
it's been nice even in the release of it
it's been really really nice
and just to see so many people support a
story
um that needed to be supported did you
know king esther was going to be
released on issa rey's channel during
the screenwriting process i
did not know that i had no i didn't even
think it was going to be possible
to be honest with you because she has so
many fantastic
productions and so many people are
reaching out to them and their team
to get access to their platform because
of what is able to do to transform your
career
so i just really wrote it from a place
of authenticity and then it was just
nice to be on the other end and just see
this is the path that was laid and
designed for it
but no idea none what's that process
like once you finally
sort of get an email yes or maybe how
does that work
sure so once somebody like a issa rate
presents says yes we want to take your
series then they have to make sure that
you have a really strong
chain of title so that you all like the
documentation that goes with saying
that this is absolutely your production
and that there's no type of copyright
infringement that kind of exists within
the context of the series but we also
were able to use fair usage
licensing because it was a series that
is really saying something more
it's not just entertainment value it
also has a lot of educational components
to it as well
so then we got there then we had to put
together a partnership agreement
we had a lot of meetings to discuss the
approach
how we wanted to release how we wanted
to give gain access
and traction we would come visit that
kind of in the middle of the series
and we just kind of put it all together
and then october 17th we released the
series and then every thursday after
we were just able to put it out so
that's how the process went
and what time frame is that so it took
us about
two months two months from the time that
they said yes because the production was
already ready to go since we already had
all of our paperwork together we already
had our book
we already had our channel title we
didn't have to go make any of those
things happen
which is again the advantage of
professionalism and knowing
this is what you need in order to get
this deal secured so it was about a
two-month process
and everything happened really fast
everything happened
really quick and before we knew it it
was like out
it was like what you know it did really
really good
what do you think people get wrong with
wanting to do a web series b
are you think they're writing for the
market instead of how you said you
didn't know so you're just writing a
story that you want to tell based on
the feedback you were getting right i
think what happens a lot of times um
most of the digital series that i see
are usually actors
who want to showcase themselves inside
of a
a series which is fine there's nothing
wrong with that
but i think what happens when everything
is a direct reflection of you some of
the rigorous approach that you need to
take to some of the flaws that the
character may have
or even some of the performance that an
actor may give
gets lost because the series is 100
about them right so i think what
really unlocks a little bit of magic in
you
and to not make it so personal and make
it more objective
is to be able to tell a story that
necessarily you don't own
maybe an experience that you have but
it's not necessarily about
you as a creator and
also we've seen so many friends
in our department living together
talking about life
we've seen so many of these things so i
think the freshness of king esther was
that
not only was it a digital series but it
was a new approach
it's like oh this is one day and it was
there were some dark
very dark elements to the series so to
see something that they have not seen
before allow
people to kind of hang on to the series
a little bit more
because you know people quickly move
past you on
the internet
right i like that yeah you're right
there have been a lot of friends in
apartments
where were you when it went live so we
were at the new orleans film festival
so we made the product in new orleans we
loved the new orleans film festival we
wanted to one day
possibly get in and we actually got into
the festival
and we decided to release it the day
after the screening
so we were in new orleans and we were
having a big party when it was online
and everybody was seeing it
wow yeah it was it was so serendipitous
and it was it could have been more
perfect
and so did you reflect in that moment
like
this all that i went through if this is
what i had i think this is worth it
yes it made it it made it all worth it
all the casts were able to come back to
new orleans and be there
and just to see how full of circles
something's come
we could have never designed it more
perfectly than what it was able
than how it was able to happen and it
was nice to be able to be there
be inspired breathe the same air eat the
same food which
i gained a lot of weight that week
but it was all worth it because i think
new orleans is such a special
and unique city that has given so much
to me so it was so nice to be there
as we released our series you went to
college there
i went to school in louisiana so i went
to in baton rouge i went to lsu
and then moved to new orleans right
after right after i finished
what is it that's so special i've never
been there i've always wanted to go but
what is it
that's so special so there's a culture
that um and an ownership of that culture
that the people have
that just you know when someone loves
their city and they treat it with their
same love
and respect and that dignity and it's a
city that's kind of unlike american
cities where
tradition is king and so everything that
they do
has a traditional element to it from the
second lines
to mardi gras and how they have the
people in the city actually have the
mardi gras experience
to how they eat food on sundays in these
really big pots and
you know so it's it's a it's a culture
that's steeped in
traditions to to be able to participate
and understand those traditions is what
makes it so special
and i don't think there's any city in
the in the world quite like new orleans
and after hurricane katrina did you
notice
changes in how the community came
together or
yeah so it was really interesting so i
was there before and after hurricane
katrina i moved back maybe
a year and a half afterwards and in a
lot of ways it was
it had this very like darkness to it i
mean
all the lights weren't on in the city
when i got back
the grounds the median wasn't being cut
on a regular basis when i got back it
was still very much a city that was in
peril
and in the stage of rebuilding now
you're able to see a lot of the
gentrification that has taken place and
a lot of the residents that were in new
orleans that had never left
actually when they got out they never
came back and so you see
the city in a different way than i saw
the city
prior to august 28 2005
but there's still there's still really
beautiful element
the people have some of the people have
moved back and have continued to
maintain
those traditions that have been able to
continue to make the city
extremely special so some of that is
gone because of gentrification
it's gone i mean some of the history was
washed away in the storm
um i mean when you just really think
about
some of the evidence that was needed for
like a legal fights and battles were
gone
lives were lost through that process
homes were forever destroyed and not
rebuilt
so the city is completely transformed
as opposed to what it was prior to but
the spirit of the city is the same and
it's um
it's beautiful to see that they've had
the resurgence and that they're doing
well
and it's still as beautiful as it was
before do you almost consider that more
your home
i don't actually i love new orleans but
i struggled
i had such a hard time when i was living
in new orleans um
i didn't have any money was very hard
for me to find a job very hard for me to
get anything
all i had was enough money to get a
dollar and 14
cents muffin to be able to write in the
cc's coffee house
every day that i was writing in and all
i did was just write every single day
because i didn't
kept down the hunger pains to be quite
honest with you
and it kept me distracted from the
reality of life that i was actually
having it was very very tough
because i was young and trying to make
something out of nothing in a city that
wasn't
[Music]
an environment that could cultivate my
career and so it was
very very difficult and while i love new
orleans i don't see it as like
my home i feel like much more of a new
yorker
oh okay much more of a new yorker i felt
at home from the first day
i love new york with creating content
that you wanted to create working with
issa rae
did you feel you were finally where you
wanted to be
yes i feel like that's where i was
supposed to be
that's why we made the decision to go
with issa rae presents on the color
creative
youtube channel because we knew that
there was an audience that was there
that was specifically for
us and issa ray and denise
make sure that they allow voices to be
to to be the voice that they are they
didn't ask us to change
anything they just wanted to amplify the
voice
that a perspective that we had already
given so it was just so nice to be at a
place that didn't ask you to change
anything
so you could just be dewey yeah i could
just do my do a thing
yeah that's the kind of environments
that i look for nice
yeah and and does that part of like sort
of the test
as to where you want to be or what you
want to do
is do i feel like i can be me and i'm
not being
controlled into being someone else right
yes that is that is an
important component to me being able to
flourish as a filmmaker
while yes still being able to accept and
work with others in order
to make my work better because it's
still a very collaborative effort to
creating
a film product you can do it on your own
it's impossible
but to be able to do it the way that i
see
myself being able to do it i mean you
can have a starbucks
or you can have cc's coffee house
they're not going to do
coffee the same way but you can still
enjoy the cup
sure and so it's the same way with me
it's like you can enjoy my product but
you can also enjoy the process of doing
it as well
making sure people get lunch breaks
making sure people feel seen
making sure people feel heard in a way
that a lot of sets don't necessarily run
themselves
and so i get it it's just the way that i
do things and it's my approach to
storytelling because i wanted to feel
authentic
behind the camera and in front of the
camera as well
what does filmmaking give you that you
don't get anywhere else
joy a pure a pureness in the joy
and it gives me a focus that i don't
have anywhere else in my life like
in a lot of ways my actual life is a
mess
but my film career is okay you know
because it's just
i have a focus like i can wake up in the
morning and know like this is the story
and i'm telling and i get to collaborate
with other beings and other creative
souls and entities who are trying to get
to somewhere creative
as well it gives me such pleasure and
such joy to be able to do that and to be
able to define it as a career
because it wasn't a career when i first
started it was a
a desire it was a goal but it wasn't a
career and now
i'm comfortably in a place where
it's a career for me and i'm actually
being paid to write
screenplays or to put together
productions
for um for brands and it's really really
nice to be able to do that
what's your advice to someone that is in
a small town
that's creative maybe they don't feel
like they fit in
they love people there but they want to
break out
yeah i get it i get it i was there for a
really long time
and the reality is is at some point you
will have to
get out depending on whatever your
eventual goal
and your desire is but to create where
you are
when i first moved to new orleans and
made my first short film
i wasn't in l.a but it mattered right it
gave me the skills that i needed to put
together
a team and to lead that team i did
a good 10 other films in louisiana
before i made my feature film
and i did that in atlanta georgia you
know and so it's just
you know where you are create where you
are
because you're going to need those
skills as you move further and further
along down the line
and one thing that i do see difficult
and i i
identify with a lot of these people who
go to film school
where the the process is set up for you
it's told
you know you don't have to go find a
script supervisor there's somebody
that's there that's going to be a script
supervisor
and so when they get out and get into
the real world they really struggle
because the foundation
to create is not established for them
they have to go
make it happen for themselves so
creators like myself who have that
fortitude to just get out and make it
happen
it'll give you a competitive advantage
when you actually get into the real
world because this is how
you actually have to put it together you
got to barter you got to work with
people you got to have people
intelligence
you have to have all those things in
order to just get your work out
in the most nuanced way that you
possibly can
i think there's a danger to being a
creator in a small town
i do think that it doesn't have
its advantages so one thing about being
in a small town is you're not gonna
your crew is not gonna be as nearly as
talented as what you would like them to
be
um i mean just a first ac you don't
think about how
much a first ac matters until you're in
a situation where a first ac
saves your production right a script
supervisor
a lot so in a lot of those small towns
you don't have
access to those resources to be able to
put it together at a very high level
but again once you're able to put a film
together and you have to be smart and
savvy about putting it together
without a script supervisor when you get
a script supervisor you're like oh
i'm living a good life you make a film
without a monitor you
like i don't even know how i miss this
miss that and the other
until you get a monitor you're like oh
i'm living a good life so for me
everything that i get i feel like i'm in
disney world now i'm like oh
i have two acs in this film department
like let's go
you know where before you're training
the person on how to hold the boom mic
properly
and so those are the disadvantages but
it's such a refining
of you as a filmmaker and it's a
necessary lesson
that you will be able to carry all the
way up to hbo production
do you think it's dangerous for a
creator to be in a small town and create
the backlash sometimes um i think it
depends on what the creator's saying
if the creator is really moving the net
the the needle forward in a dark place
there probably could necessarily be some
backlash or
they're doing subject matter that is you
know not
um socially acceptable
whatever their society may be so there
could be some dangers but the beautiful
thing is the internet really just levels
the playing field because now you can
find an audience
even if it's not directly where you are
you can find
an audience to connect with your work
and i mean whether that's a comedy
or whether it's a a really
a sahora you can find your audience and
so
the internet is able to accomplish a lot
of those disadvantages that small towns
kind of give you nowadays
one of your quotes on your website is
about surrounding yourself with certain
types of creatives
there's like three qualities what are
those qualities and why do they matter
to you
so the three qualities that just really
make the difference for me and working
with someone is generosity
it is intellectual curiosity and
accountability
and what i had found in my career was
where are the pitfalls that i'm kind of
running into sometimes you would work
with someone
and a decision would be made and nobody
would want to be
accountable for that well i don't want
to work with people who don't
engage in being accountable because
accountable just means you take
responsibility for the decisions that
you made
and then one of the things that i am
just by nature is i'm a very generous
person
and so i want to work with other
creators who are just as
generous because if you're able to give
to each other then that gives everybody
more
to be able to hold on to and i also
have when i'm making something or i'm
constructing a narrative
or i'm getting stuck on a shot list or
how i want to approach it
i find that intellectual vigor or
intellectual curiosity is really the
thing that solves the problem
like how we as a team can come together
to overcome it to make the best decision
possible
that's going to assist this story and so
those are the those are the things that
i need
and they they work beautifully when
you're able to have that cohesive team
on set and i think it's always just
reflected beautifully
in the final product
when should an artist quit their day job
i honestly think an artist should quit
their day job
under two circumstances when the day job
is either inhibiting
your ability to create your art or when
you have found the financial resources
to be able to live comfortably within
your art
that happened for me a year ago i had a
job for
some time and i just
i said this is keeping me from being
able to really engage and
do my art and so i left it it was
probably one of the best decisions that
i ever made
as opposed to how i went the first time
because it was more on my terms and it
mattered to me
to be able to just create art full-time
so i think those are the two
circumstances that identify when you
should actually leave your job
yeah it must be really empowering to
know that you you saw the force
you did it on your own it wasn't where
somebody was pushing you out or
you felt you had to like hang on right
took that sort of
right and i was no more prepared to be
quite honest with you it wasn't like i
had
saved this you know incredible amount of
money to be able to live for like a year
none of those things happen but i just
knew my heart was telling me that it was
time to go
and so i unlocked that fear
i walked through it and i was so happy
that i did because right on the other
side i was able to get a job
that really paid you know a fair amount
of money for maybe to live on for
some time and i've continued to see
different opportunities
to just arise to say hey and it's
kind of carrying me forward so it was
the right decision to make and i'm glad
that i made it
what was the worst year you had as a
filmmaker the year
the worst year i had as a filmmaker was
definitely the year after i created
lesson before love
um it's just the difficulty of
holding this production in my hand
because it's my child and i sometimes
will always say it was like having a
child before i was ready to have a child
because you still have to get this child
ready you have to
put this child on his feet and send it
to a film festival and you have to do
this
and so i had all these accountabilities
and responsibilities towards this film
project but i didn't even have the
personal resources to take care of
myself
and so it was an extremely extremely
dark ear
for me a lot of times i kind of don't
even really want to reflect on it
because of how difficult it was
to know that you have this really good
product but you don't even have the
resources to eat
that day but you got to edit so editing
on
empty stomach is incredibly difficult
it's not inspired editing
you know you're just trying to get
through it and we made so many mistakes
on that project and we lost
um we did we lost so much along the
process but we
did the absolute best
you could do with 45 thousand dollars
and that's why i'm so proud of that
project because it's like ah
i mean what i was able to accomplish
with nothing was remarkable
but it was a very very dark time
when did it turn around for you it
didn't turn around for like another year
and a half
after i made that production and it had
nothing to do with the production
it started to i started to take care of
myself and so i was like oh
i need a job you know i needed to get an
apartment i needed to do
the things that i needed to do for my
mental health
and so i started to do those things i'm
exercising regularly eating better
actually hanging out engaging in
meeting people and you know just all the
things that i needed to be doing not
stuck in a lab just edited in a film
so it was a lot on the other side of
that and that's why i thought it was
going to be
impossible for me to go back there
because it was so much pain when i was
there
and so now as i'm approaching doing my
next feature film again
i just hope and trust that it will be
different this time around
and you like to write in noisy loud
coffee shops
i do i do and believe it or not i'm able
to focus
because it's like so much going on
around me i'm like i know stay here
as opposed to being home and just
sitting and thinking like oh
i wonder who wrote downton abbey and
then looking it up online
you know so it just gives me a different
kind of like focus to be able to just
write in a in a busy environment it just
makes sense for me for whatever reason
do people ever try to talk to you and
ask you what are you doing and
yeah i engage in coffee talk i'm cool
with coffee talk you know the coffee
talk doesn't really bother me
um what i find though is a lot there's a
lot of very respectful creators out here
because everybody's trying to create
even people that have successfully done
it
everybody's still trying to create so
it's nice to be able to work with
different people who still respect the
process
and we call them like um writing dates
so i just meet up with other creators
and we'll
we'll write together for like eight
hours and we'll just call it like a
writing date and you know we'll
engage a conversation here and there but
yeah we do
yeah there is something um interesting
about being in a busy space
because you can almost tune out some of
that stuff but it
it keeps you i don't know if there's a
different energy to it yeah it is
and i feel like sometimes some people
should give it a try whereas
in the past maybe you would think that
too much chaos is not good it actually
can be
invigorating it really can be in a lot
of ways so i agree with you 100
yeah and you see some interesting stuff
happen in those coffee shops
you do and they might end up in your
story
what's on the horizon for you so next is
a feature film
called the inevitable sadness of all
things good which is the original work
that king esther was derived from
so that is my focus is to do my next my
second feature film actually
i only did one so and the protagonist is
not actually esther
no it's my brother it's her brother king
and the series the
the film excuse me is about um king
trying to start a church
as hurricane katrina comes to town so
he's trying to start a church for the
hood
in the hood for the hood
so that's what the film is about so it's
my take on religious dogma and
dreams and the reality in the
landscape of devastation is he
a new person to the town no so he's been
in new orleans for a long time he's
a pigeon town dude and um he was
introduced in
king esther you actually saw him in the
actual series
numerous times but this time it's really
just his own journey
and what are your um what are you
feeling about this project
i'm scared i'm really scared to be quite
honest with you i've
now i know right i can't unknow how
difficult it is
to do a feature film and so one of the
things that i've been doing lately
is um letting go of the fear from the
past
and also not being anxieties anxieties
about the future
but just being present and enjoying the
present because in the present
i'm okay right and so i'm really trying
to work through
that fear and all of what i had to go
through with the first feature because
it wasn't pleasant and i don't want to
have to go through it again
but i recognize one of the agreements
that you have to make with these films
is you have to live with it no matter
what
so it might happen again right i may
lose everything again
and to face that risk um
in the landscape of this story that i
feel like is necessary to be told
is what has me fearful but it's also is
is fueling me in order to do it and
hopefully do it better than i did my
first feature film the first time
you know that saying that like if
someone was able to do something the
first time that even if they lose
everything
most likely they can do it again because
they kind of
did it on their own it wasn't like
someone just totally helping them so
do you have any of that feeling like
maybe even if things go south that you
can still
do something else yeah i realized
no matter what i lost that i would still
be without it and so it's not the things
that i'm
afraid of it's not you know the spoils
because like i said i
i lost them and i've been so blessed to
get it all back and so i'm not afraid
of losing it again but what i lost
was a sense of self and that's what i
don't want to lose
this time around i still want to
maintain my joy
i still want to maintain my desire to
create
film because i feel like if i have
another experience like i had
the first time it might break me and i
don't want to stop making films
and so there's a lot of fear there but
at the same time i think
i really i'm surrounded by really good
people
i've had these experiences i've gone
there before
and i know i'll be okay in the end and
why do you
want to attempt to go through this again
well personally
especially in recent years i've had a
lot of questions about religion
um and the effects of it
and where i am personally as it pertains
to my own
spiritual and religious journey and so
king's story has such a universal
component of
spirituality and religion with inside of
it that i just think that it's
it's the story that i have to tell in
order to heal that part of myself that
really needs that healing
and that needs that confirmation that
where i am religious-wise is where i'm
supposed to be
so it's a really um it's going to be a
challenge to be able to unlock
that magic but i think that that's there
and hopefully
you know um this film could support a
really beautiful thesis of why
we still engage and have religion
would you say it's faith-based no not at
all
not at all oh no no no it's not
faith-based but that's the idea
because it is faith-based because king
is absolutely
stepping out on faith but it's not um
it's not a religious film
that's about god as we know god to be
it's about his experience of god and his
approach
to how we should experience god and so
i think there's some fascinating
elements to it
there's some beautiful imagery that i've
already been able to encapsulate in the
side of my mind
and so hopefully i'm able to unlock this
in the fullness of how i'm dreaming it
up
and hopefully it's effective and it's a
really effective
story that people participate in
do you think people feel ashamed for
wanting to do
films questioning faith religion
i think it's a question of faith and
religion is one of those no-no's
especially in the black community you
know we're all a lot of
us especially from the south are raised
in the throes of religion
while not ever challenging that religion
and so for me i have a lot of challenges
for religion and so i think seeing
this trend to other people questioning
it as well
would really lend itself to being able
to engage and have this narrative
because i don't think god
is who we have made him out to be
and so i really want to challenge just
even our own personal view of who god is
and who god can be inside of
your best year as a filmmaker it would
have to be 2019
okay yes because i feel like i made my
best work
which has been king esther and i've been
able to move to la
i have not been destroyed by it i've
been comforted by it actually
i'm healthy i'm strong and i feel like i
have more creative vigor than i've ever
had before
so i'm really excited this 2019 has been
an amazing year for me and i'm really
grateful for it
and that was one thing you said too that
you've worked on on gratitude
yes and i and unlock that gratitude
every day all the time
make sure when i am having a negative
thought or i'm having a thought that is
debilitating to who i
am to uh to reverse that by making sure
i give gratitude
because there's so much more for me to
be grateful for and things for me to be
sad about
and so i try to make sure i unlock that
at every waking turn
through my creative journey at what
point did things start going right
for you when i let go of who
i thought i should be and embraced who i
authentically am
that has been the difference um
had i still engaged in that level of
fear that i had from less than before
love
i never would have made brooklyn blue
sky but i'm like this is what i was
supposed to make and this is why
and it's been the difference i was able
to let go of all that past
and just embrace the present and i think
that's been a difference
and and and celebrate who you are and
celebrate who i am to celebrate my
perspective
and celebrate my successes because i
think sometimes as filmmakers we get so
caught up in what the film hasn't done
we failed to
unlock gratitude for what the film is
doing
and even if it's affecting one person
right even if it only got into
the chicago international film festival
it got there
and that's something to be grateful for
and now that's how i live